LEFT AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT,
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER TODAY.
DEMOCRATS SPEND EVERY SECOND, OF
EVERY 24-HOUR DAY -- AND I'VE
SAID BEFORE IF THEY DO MAKE HE
CURED CANCER, THERE WAS STILL
HATE HIM.
WHILE DEMOCRATS WERE ALWAYS BUSY
OBSESSING ABOUT THE RUSSIA HOAX,
THE UKRAINE HOAX, IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
HARD AT WORK SINCE HE WAS
ELECTED TO END THE RESULTS, THEY
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN,
THESE ARE ACCOMPLISHMENTS, THIS
IS JUST A SIDE NOTE OF A
PRESIDENT DURING THE SINGLE MOST
DIFFICULT HYPERPARTISAN TIME IN
OUR LIFETIMES AND THROUGH IT
ALL, HE HAS STILL BEEN ABLE TO
REMAIN FOCUSED ON HIS PROMISES.
THE SUCCESS, THE TRACK RECORD IS
AMAZING.
WE HAVE THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969.
LESS THAN ONE TERM, WATCH WHAT
YOU SEE THERE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS RENEGOTIATED
TRADE DEALS WITH MEXICO, CANADA,
JAPAN, AND SOUTH KOREA.
OF COURSE THE WALL ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, IT'S GETTING
BUILT.
MORE BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE AND
HE SUCCESSFULLY POINTED TWO
CONSTITUTIONALIST JUDGES TO THE
SUPREME COURT AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHER FEDERAL JUDGES.
YES, ORIGINALIST,
CONSTITUTIONALIST, HE PASSED THE
LARGEST TAX CUTS IN HISTORY THAT
GENERATED AN ECONOMIC BOOM.
NEARLY 9 MILLION NEW JOBS
CREATED AND MILLION MORE OUT OF
POVERTY.
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
SINCE 1969.
MORE AMERICANS ARE WORKING THAN
EVER BEFORE IN HISTORY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES,
THIS COUNTRY AND 75 YEARS IS
ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND A NET
EXPORTER OF ENERGY, THE
LIFEBLOOD OF EVERY ECONOMY ON
THIS EARTH.
NONE OF IT MATTERS TO THE LEFT,
NONE OF IT MATTERS TO THEIR MOB
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA.
NONE OF IT FROM THE MOMENT HE
ENTERED OFFICE AND HE CAME DOWN
THE ESCALATOR WITH MO    -- THEY
THE ESCALATOR WITH MO    -- THED
THEIR VERY BEST TO DEFEAT HIM.
THEN OF COURSE THE DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, THE VERY THING THEY ARE
ACCUSING HIM OF, THEY WERE
GUILTY OF.
IT IS A NEVER ENDING UNCEASING
AND HYSTERIA, LIES, HOAXES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND NOW IT
IS A REAL CLEAR PRESENT DANGER
TO THIS REPUBLIC.
REMEMBER BEN FRANKLIN?
MONARCHY, OR A PUBLIC -- A
REPUBLIC IF YOU CAN KEEP IT.
I'M NOT SO CERTAIN WE ARE GOING
TO KEEP IT.
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY NOW WHERE
SIMPLE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL FACTS
OF OBJECTIVE TRUTH, BASIC TRUTH,
OBVIOUS TRUTH, THE RULE OF LAW,
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNANCE IS IN
JEOPARDY TONIGHT AND THE DAMAGE
MAY BE IRREPARABLE.
NOW LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY, HERE WE
ARE ALL OVER AGAIN.
IT'S NOT RUSSIA, IT'S UKRAINE,
UKRAINE.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, THIS IS NEVER
BEEN ABOUT GETTING TO THE TRUTH
NOR ABOUT SERVING THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
ALL THIS IS ABOUT FOR THEM IS
POWER AND AN INEXPLICABLE HATRED
AND RAGE TOWARDS DONALD TRUMP.
RENDER WHAT CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN
SAID IN MAY, DEMOCRATS DON'T
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT -- HE IS
LIKELY TO WIN REELECTION.
THAT PRETTY MUCH SUMS IT UP, THE
END GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE IS NO PATH, NO CRIMES,
HIGH CRIMES, MISDEMEANORS, ABUSE
OF POWER -- NONE OF THAT.
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS,
DEMOCRATS HAVE FAILED TIME AND
AGAIN.
WE HAVE MANY OPTIONS AND MANY
CHOICES ON IMPEACHMENT, WE'LL
JUST PICK ONE AND IF THERE IS NO
QUID PRO QUO WILL LOWER THE BAR.
HYSTERIA NOW SURROUNDING UKRAINE
IS NO DIFFERENT.
DEVIN NUNES ONE OF HIS FINEST
MOMENTS IN CONGRESS, HE SUMMED
IT UP PERFECTLY -- LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT.
>> I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
DEMOCRATS ON THE ROLLOUT OF THE
LATEST INFORMATIONAL WARFARE
OPERATION AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
AND THE EXTRAORDINARY ABILITY TO
ONCE AGAIN ENLIST THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IN THEIR CAMPAIGN.
THIS OPERATION BEGAN WITH MEDIA
REPORTS FROM THE PRIME
INSTIGATORS OF THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX, THAT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS CLAIMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE AN AFFAIR
PROMISE TO A FOREIGN LEADER.
THE RELEASE TRANSCRIPT OF THAT
CALL HAS ALREADY DEBUNKED THAT
CENTRAL ASSERTION BUT THAT
DIDN'T MATTER, THE DEMOCRATS
SIMPLY MOVED TO THE GOALPOSTS.
>> Sean: PAY ATTENTION, THE
MEDIA MOB WILL NEVER REPORT
THIS.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT.
THE COMPLAINT RELIED ON NOT A
REAL WHISTLE-BLOWER, HEARSAY
EVIDENCE, REPORTS FROM THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
I GUESS ANYONE IN AMERICA CAN BE
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
JUST HAVE YOUR FRIENDS GET
TOGETHER AND WRITE IT UP IN A
LAWYERLY WAY.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DETERMINED
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAD A
POLITICAL BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, NO SHOCK THERE.
HE OR SHE IS REPRESENTED BY A
LAW FIRM THAT ACTUALLY PAYS FOR
LEAKING FROM THE GOVERNMENT,
THEY EVEN HAVE ONE OF THEIR
BILLBOARDS OUTSIDE OF LANGLEY
WHERE THE CIA IS.
EITHER WAY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INVESTIGATED A
COMPLAINT, IT DIDN'T TAKE THEM
LONG TO DETERMINE ZERO CRIMES
WERE COMMITTED, NONE, ZIP --
THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO, THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT AND EVEN THE
FOREIGN MINISTER BOTH DENYING
BEING PRESSURED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN ANY WAY.
THE DEMOCRATS LATEST PLOY,
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT IS BEYOND
A DUD.
YOU SEE THAT GUY THERE, HE'S THE
BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS, HIS
NAME IS THE COWARDLY ADAM SCHIF
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE MADE UP HIS OWN VERSION OF
THE TRANSCRIPT THAT WE ALL READ
YESTERDAY, IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT
SOME NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER SAID BUT WE HAD
THE INFORMATION YESTERDAY.
ALL OF THIS, WE READ IT
YESTERDAY AND THERE WAS NOTHING
IN THERE AT ALL THAT THEY
CLAIMED WOULD BE IN THERE.
HE PERFORMED A DRAMATIC READING
FOR ALL OF HIS ADORING FANS BACK
IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE I SHOW YOU
THE CLIP, I WANT TO MAKE THIS
CLEAR.
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO PLAY YOU IS
NOT THE TRANSCRIPT BETWEEN TRUMP
AND HIS UKRAINIAN
COUNTERPARTS -- THAT WOULDN'T
WORK.
THAT'S CALLED TRUTH, OBJECTIVE
TRUTH.
BUT HE DOES IS PURE FICTION.
THIS IS A FANTASY THAT HE
DECIDED TO SHARE AT TODAY'S
HEARING, THE GUY THAT WAS CAUGHT
ON TAPE LITERALLY COLLUDING WITH
SOMEONE HE THOUGHT WAS A RUSSIAN
TO DIG UP DIRT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
WATCH THE LIAR IN ACTION.
>> THIS IS THE ESSENCE OF WHAT
THE PRESIDENT COMMUNICATES.
WE'VE BEEN VERY GOOD TO YOUR
COUNTRY, VERY GOOD.
NO OTHER COUNTRY DOES IS MUCH AS
WE HAVE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, I DON'T SEE
MUCH RECIPROCITY HERE.
I HEAR WHAT YOU WANT, I HAVE A
FAVOR THAT I WANT FROM YOU.
I'M GOING TO SAY THIS ONLY SEVEN
TIMES SO YOU BETTER LISTEN GOOD.
I WANT YOU TO MAKE UP DIRT ON MY
POLITICAL OPPONENT, UNDERSTAND?
LOTS OF IT.
ON THIS AND ON THAT.
>> Sean: THE TRANSCRIPT WAS
SO, WHY DID MR. SCHIFF HAVE TO
MAKE UP HIS OWN VERSION.
EVERYTHING SCHIFF AND HIS
COLLEAGUES ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT
OF DOING, THEY THEMSELVES ARE
GUILTY -- THAT WOULD BE CALLED
PROJECTION.
LET'S LOOK AT THE TOPIC OF
COLLUSION, DEMOCRATS FALSELY
CLAIMING OVER AND OVER AGAIN THE
PRESIDENT COLLUDED WITH A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
IF THAT WAS REALLY BAD, IT WAS
ACTUALLY ADAM SCHIFF -- DID
VLADIMIR SEE THEM?
HE GOT NAILED BY TWO PRANKSTERS
WHO SAID THEY WERE FROM RUSSIA
AND THEY SAID HE WAS TRYING TO
GET DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP TO
IMPACT THE ELECTIONS.
IN 2017, IN EARLY JANUARY,
POLITICO ISSUED A REPORT ABOUT
THE DNC'S REAL UKRAINIAN
COLLUSION.
DEMOCRATS CARED ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION, WHY DIDN'T THEY CARE
ABOUT UKRAINIAN COLLUSION?
LOOK AT POLITICO, A 32 MINUTE
READ ACCORDING TO THEIR
ESTIMATES.
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
TRIED TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON
AND UNDERMINED TRUMP BY PUBLICLY
QUESTIONING HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE.
THEY ALSO DISSEMINATED DOCUMENTS
IMPLICATING A TOP TRUMP MADE
INCORRUPTION AND THEY SUGGESTED
THEY WERE INVESTIGATING THE
MATTER ONLY TO BACK AWAY FROM
THE ELECTION AND THEY HELD
CLINTON'S ALLIES, DNC OPERATIVES
THAT SAW INFORMATION FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY TO HELP IMPACT
THE ELECTION TO GET DAMAGING
INFORMATION FROM TRUMP AND HIS
ADVISORS.
THEY DID THIS WITH THE HELP OF A
HIGHLY PAID DNC OPERATIVES.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED REAL
COLLUSION AND A HYSTERIA, AND IT
CALLS FOR INVESTIGATION, NOPE --
THIS IS A POLITICAL GAME ONLY IF
YOU CAN BLUDGEON TRUMP.
DON'T CARE ABOUT REAL COLLUSION,
DON'T CARE ABOUT QUID PRO QUO,
LOOK AT SLEEPY, CREEPY, JOE AND
HE IS IN SERIOUS TROUBLE ABOUT
WHAT OUR LEGITIMATE CREDIBLE
CLAIMS THAT HE LEVERAGED A
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
MONEY.
MAYBE IF HE CALLED AND SAID CAN
I TALK TO AS A FATHER -- MAYBE
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN DIFFERENT BUT
HE USED OUR MONEY TO GET A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WARNED HIM
AND HE TRIED MANY TIMES TO GET
THIS GUY FIRED AND EVENTUALLY
SUCCEEDED, HE SAID YOU GOT SIX
HOURS.
THEY FIRED HIM.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE SOURCES AS
VICE PRESIDENT IN 2014, HE WAS
APPOINTED POINT PERSON BY OBAMA
IN UKRAINE.
JOE'S SON HUNTER SCORED A
LUCRATIVE POSITION ON THE BOARD
OF A UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS GIAN
GIANT.
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL,
GAS, ENERGY, NO EXPERIENCE
ANYBODY CAN FIND.
IN NOVEMBER 2015, HE WAS TOLD BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HIS SON IS
UNDER THE INVESTIGATION BY
UKRAINIAN AUTHORITIES.
DECEMBER 2015 HE MADE HIS FIRST
REQUEST TO THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE TO FIRE THE LEADING
PROSECUTOR LOOKING INTO THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE COMPANY
ENDED THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
HUNTER BIDEN.
IN MARCH OF 2016, JOHN SOLOMON
REPORTS HE WAS INVESTIGATING HIS
SON.
THAT IS WHEN BIDEN LEVERAGED
YOUR MONEY COME A BILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS, FORCED THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT TO FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR, THAT WOULD BE A
BILLION REASONS WHY HE HAD TO
END BIDEN CLAIMS THE PROSECUTOR
WAS CORRUPT AND THAT'S WHAT HE
WANTED HIM TO GO.
HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE THE
BILLION DOLLAR QUID PRO QUO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS SON'S